[Music]
hi my name's star Freeman tell we're
here at scarce Pizza located the Lower
East Side of Manhattan New York Pizza is
different from Italian pizza different
from Detroit self is like New York
pizzas a cultural thing
it doesn't matter what where the person
is from and owns it doesn't matter what
their background is it's just a food
that unites everyone I mean it's changed
a lot but the core in essence of New
York Pizza was always for slice shoppers
the response that viewers fulfilling but
it's too gooey or undercooked I'm not
trying to like rip off its Lamoni or
anything so they use a different cheese
and sauce but I always like having the
cheese on the bottom sauce on top
especially well the way we make our
pizza here in scarves is it's an upside
down so you layered cheese and then this
alehrer salt right on top and then we
coat it with more cheese on top with the
artisans up I mean a lot of spots use
cheaper [ __ ] I'm like if they say I use
cheap [ __ ] I bring them downstairs I got
a still no operating nothing's can't
except for model wall and I'll show you
invoices - I'm paying to do the roof the
sauce we users are using organic sauce
so we buy sauce that doesn't come in
cans it's a strain tomatoes to Posada we
season it simple just a little salt
garlic oregano fresh basil little black
pepper you just want to seize it enough
where you could bring out the robust
until the tomato there's no grape jelly
like massive amounts of sugar like the
satisfy sauce it's a real tomato we use
about four different cheeses two
different mozzarellas and two different
hard cheese
we actually allow our notice it for
about four days through the four days we
allowed it ferment for 24 hours outside
cold from - three days and then allowed
it ferment again outside for another
couple hours a day that we use once it
showed up roof then I Harvick is allowed
to cool down and put a layer of cheese
and I cooked that off and then cook it a
third time with the sausage you want a
layer of sauce to sit on top so it
doesn't dry out the cheese's underneath
or any one in Manhattan lived in Long
Island City in a store to be a building
honestly I wasn't planning on opening up
in New Yorkers I thought it was past
that stage New York was very fast I said
you know hey before you know if you're
not a gram friendly restaurant or
Instagram friendly restaurant if you're
not you're not licking someone's balls
in the food industry it's like you don't
have a shot basically I don't give a
[ __ ] what you do if you're not like I'm
not a guy to grew up kiss and ask them
like that's not my stuff like when the
whole Brooklyn thing blew up was the
last five six years or book opens I'm
like that kind of inspired me because
it's like there was a great slide shot
since my Hatton there's great slide
shops in the Bronx there's great slide
shops of Queens like Brooklyn did not
invent this life so this day just will
probably find a great slide shop in
Manhattan or the Browns anywhere else
you know it's a small spot you wanted to
show people kind of be in your face like
we're from New York we're really from
New York this is our culture we just
wanted to create a that last remnant of
like real New York